[Music]  hi here to get your passport photo taken  just head into the room there and we'll  get started step between the lights  please  that's great okay smile oh do you have  anything else you could wear could you  try something else on  no tell you what how about just no shirt  at all let's try that  you  yeah that's gonna work better here we go  oh those pants don't work with the  lighting could you roll up your pants or  you know what just take take the pants  off too  okay that's good really nice yeah it's  very nice how about we lose the  underwear you sick son of a [ __ ] stop  him  you'll never take me alive ow hey ow  [Music]  ah  [Music]  five six eight  very bad nutsack I told you so far he's  a fat thank you Wow good job kid you're  quite the fighter all right let's get  this over with  say cheese Congrats kid you have your  first Passport  [Music]